اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا هذه التغطيه لا
زالت مستمره للتطورات في السودان انقضاء
موعد الهدنه التي اعطت املا بوقف المعارك
في السودان ولم يلتزم فيها اي من الاطراف
اصوات القصف والاشتباكات لم تهدا خاصه في
محيط مبنى القياده العمل للجيش رغم
تاكيدات الجيش والدعم السريع نيتهما
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24 ساعه
احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عانى وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا وا اكثر من 1800
شخص بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك
صعب يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت مساعدات لا يمكنني اعطائك
اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه الممتلكات
المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه او حتى
المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال كما قلت
في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا يمكن ان
يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل اساسي تمديد
وقلق اماميان واطراف اقليميه ودوليه تقف
على خط الازمه التي ساحت ثالثه اكبر بلد
افريقي الا ان تلك المساعي والمحاولات
المتعدده لم تجد اذانا صاغيه حتى الان
سلطان العيبان العربيه
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر تطورات المتعلقه بهذه الازمه
وجهها وللخرطوم المكلفه احمد عثمان حمزه
بعوده محطات مياه الشرب للعمل بشكل عاجل
وذلك خلال الاجتماع لاداره الازمه مع
مسؤولين عن الخدمات ومديري محليات
وطمئنا وللخرطوم الى جاهزيه محطات المياه
بعد تعرض عدد منها لاعطال جراء القصف ما
تسبب بانقطاع الامداد المائي عن الاحياء
السكنيه لافتا الى توفير قوات او قوات
لتامين القوى العامله في الصيانات الاعطال
وتناول هذا الاجتماع جهود وزاره الصحه في
تامين العلاج باقسام الطوارئ والعمل مع
الجهات الامنيه لحمايه تحركات الكوادر
الطبيه وتامين وصول الادويه الى
المستشفيات
اليوم عقدنا اجتماع لحكومه الولايه في
اطار مسؤوليتنا تجاه مواطني ولايه الخرطوم
نحن
ركزنا في هذا الاجتماع على
الانسياب الخدمات في مقدمه هذه الخدمات هي
مياه الشرب حيث تاثرت العديد من محطات
المياه
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي او
بحاله امنيه حاله دون قيام العاملين
بواجبهم الان بدات هذه المحطات تعود
بالتدريج ان شاء الله
ويتحسن الامداد المائي في سعه القادمه
باذن الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
الطاوله التي جلس سائل الجهه واحده منها
للسنوات انقلبت والوساطه باتت مطلوبه لوعد
المواجهه المسلحه بينهما في مهد العاصمه
بعد اربعه ايام على انزلاق رجلين الحكم
العسكري في السودان الى مستنقع القتال
سيناريوهات ثلاثه محتمله رسمت لمستقبل
المواجهه بين قائد القوات المسلحه ونائبه
السيناريو الاول ذهب الى حرب الشوارع
طويله تنحصر في العاصمه مع محاوله كل طرف
فيها حسم المعركه لمصلحته لكنه ينتهي
بانتشار قوات الجيش السوداني في كافه
المناطق والاحياء فاعتماد الجيش
استراتيجيه استنزاف الموارد وتفوقه من
ناحيه المعدات العسكريه والطائرات قد يكون
نقطه الفصل على ارض المعركه حيث ستفقد
قوات الدعم السريع ذات التسليح الخفيف
والمتوسط مؤنها من وقود وذخيره وغذاء خلال
ثلاثه ايام من الاشتباك المتواصل اول
السيناريوهات رجح انسحاب احمدتي تكتيكيا
الى دارفور في حال حوصره من الجيش ليتظلل
بقواته المتمرده مجردا من اي مناصبه او
مشاركه بالمشهد السياسي الا في حال
التسويه اما السيناريو الثاني فيتمثل بوقف
لاطلاق النار بعد وسطات عربيه وغربيه يليه
بدء عمليه التفاوض والمحاكمات العسكريه
لينتهي بدمج قوات الدعم السريع المتبقيه
مع الجيش
بما يشمل السيناريو الثالث وقف اطلاق
النار وعوده الجميع للتسويه وهنا الاحتمال
المطروح عدم وجود قوات الدعم السريع كطرف
رئيسيا في العمليه التفاوضيه والذهاب
لفتره انتقاليه جديده تهيئ للانتخابات
ونرصد الاوضاع من مدينه مروي مع مراسل
العربيه نزار بزار اهلا بك معنا مبدئيا
كيف هي الصوره اخر تفاصيل الميدانيه نبدا
بها من مرويه
اخر التفاصيل هي ما يتعلق بحاله الهدوء
النسبي الذي تعيشه مدينه مروي هذه المدينه
التي كانت على وقع احداث عسكريه خلال
ثلاثه ايام الماضيه اليوم وحسب مصادر
عسكريه افادت بان القوه التي كانت تتمركز
داخل مطار مروي الدولي قد غادرت او انسحبت
او اضطره الانسحاب من هذه القاعده
واتجهت جنوبا وبعدها مباشره الطيران
العسكري تعامل مع من خرج من هذه القاعده
يقدر باكثر من 130 سياره تتبع لقوات الدعم
السريع اتجهت جنوبا تعامل معها الطياره
الطيران الحربي وشهود عيان من المواطنين
اكدوا التفرق لقوات الدعم السريع
بسياراتهم في عدد من الطرق جنوب قاعده
مروي في حدود 100 كم
الاوضاع هنا في
نزار مع مغادرتهم من صار يسيطر
مطار في هذه المرحله يعني تتحدث على
انسحاب او خروج حتى تتاكد وتتواضح اكثر
المعلومه نحو 130 سياره تابعه لدعم السريع
من مطار مروي مع خروجهم من متى يسيطر على
المطار في هذه الاثناء
الان هنالك قوات تتبع للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه هي الان في محيط المطار وداخل
المطار
الاعلام العسكري كان قد بثت تصوير من داخل
المطار قال بانه داخل مطار مروي وداخل
القاعده اظهر جنود يتبعون للجيش السوداني
وبمعيتهم سيارات تتبع للجيش واسلحه تتبع
للجيش قالوا بانهم يصورون هذا المقطع من
داخل مطار مروي ومن داخل القاعده وكانت
ايضا مصادر تحدثت بالعربيه بان الجيش قد
وصل الى داخل المطار وقد استخدم المدفعيه
الثقيله من اجل ابعاد عناصر قوات الدعم
السريع من داخل المطار هذا فما يخص مطار
مروي ثم يخص القاعده فيما يخص بقيه
المراكز التي
كان السريع كيف هي حالتها حتى الان كيف هو
التطور فيما يخصها
قوات الدعم السريع كانت تتمركز فقط داخل
القاعده والمطار والمطار
يضم الى جانبه القاعده في مساحه تقدر بنحو
18 كيلو متر مربع في هذه المساحه فقط كانت
تدور الراحه العمليه العسكريه لمده اربعه
ايام
كان فقط لنفهم جغرافيه هذا المكان القاعده
تبعد على المطار هي القاعده
هي الملحقه ملحقه بالمطار طيب
كل العمليه العسكريه كانت تدور في هذه
المنطقه بدات في الجانب
الجنوبي من المطار انتقلت الى وسط المطار
القاعده تقع في الجزء الشمالي من المطار
والمطار العسكري يقع في الجانب الجنوبي من
المطار وهنالك ايضا جزء للطيران المدني
اذا ما دعت الضروره هذا هو المسرح
الميداني العسكري لهذه العمليه قوات الدعم
السريع كانت فقط في هذا الاطار الجغرافي
الضيق ليس هنالك من تمدد لم تتمدد في قرى
في مدن في مساحات انما كان النشاط وكان
الاشتباك وكانت العمليات فقط في حدود هذه
الجغرافيا هل يمكن الحديث عن هدوء حذر
تشهده مدينه مروي يعني بعد خروج قوات
الدعم السريع من المطار من القاعده وعدم
تمركزها في نقاط اخرى من المدينه هل نتحدث
عن هدوء حظر وكيف هي تخوم المدينه هل هناك
استعداد ربما لمحاوله [__] عادتها
الهدوء الحذر هذا هو الوصف الامثل لما
تعيشه مروي الان مساء المدينه حبست
انفاسها يوم الامس عندما شاهدت دارتين
جويتين لطلعتين عسكريتين جويتين
نفذتا عبر الطيران العسكري بعدها مباشره
دوت اصوات المدفعيه واصوات المضادات
الارضيه للطيران حبست انفاس المواطنين
اليوم ايضا عندما
تعاملت المدفعيه الثقيله مع وجود عناصر
الدعم السريع كانت ايضا هنالك حاله من
التوتر الان هنالك هدوء نسبي يعم المدينه
يهم ارجاع محليه مروي لكن المعلومات الان
غير مؤكده هل كل عناصر قوات الدعم السريع
هي الان خارج حدود محليه مروي ام ابتعدت
جنوبا اتجاه ام درمان اتجاه الخرطوم ام
اتجهت شرقا نحو محل نحو ولايه نهر النيل
المواطنون في ذلك الشريط الجنو
يتخوفون من عمليات اشتباك ربما يتخوفون من
عمليات قد تجعل المواطنين في مواجهه
مباشره مع هذه القوات بالتالي حاله التوتر
تظل قائمه وتظل حاضره لكن هنا في مروي حيث
توجد القاعده والمطار الاوضاع هادئه نسبيا
في ظل هذا الهدوء الحذر كما وصفته هو في
ظل
هدوء الاشتباكات الميدانيه هل هناك تحرك
لطائرات في سماء مروي بمعنى ان في الساعات
الفائته كنا نتابع بعض الاخبار المتفرقه
مفادها بان هناك طائرات استطلاع تحلق في
سماء مروي هل هذا مستمر نزار
لا ليس هنالك من طائرات الان سواء كان
للاستطلاع او الطيران الذي يقصف المواقع
بعد تحديدها الان فقط هنالك هدوء هنالك
وجود للقوات السودانيه قوات الجيش
السوداني هنالك ايضا قوات للمدفعيه موجوده
الان في المطار في محيط المطار تمركزات في
عدد من المحاور هنا في مروى
الجيش السوداني عبر تصريحاته للعربيه اكد
بانه
سيتعامل وفق متغيرات هذه العمليه العسكريه
وانه جاهز لكل السيناريوهات وضحت الفكره
نعود لك في سياق تخطيتنا من مدينه مروي
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك
في الولايات يمكن تمت السيطره عليها تماما
نحن نسيطر الان على القياده العامه
بالكامل مسيطره على مطار الخرطوم الرئاسي
اذا هذا تمرد واضح ومرود القانون العسكري
ان هذا تمرد بالنسبه للمبادرات بكل مبادره
لكن
انا اتحدث معك
المعرفه نحن ليست لدينا مشكله مع قوات
الدعم السريع احنا نفصل ما بينما يقوم به
محمد حمدان وشقيقي
هذا هو كانه وثقت كاميرا العربيه لحظه
حدوث انفجار في محيط مباني القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه في العاصمه
الخرطومونتابع
الى ذلك كانت كشفت مصادر خاصه للعربيه عن
تحركات مصريه اقليميه تشمل دخول مراقبين
دوليين للوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار خلال
عيد الفطر فتح ممرات امنه بين مصر
والسودان لمده ثمن واربعين ساعه للسماح
بنقل المصابين ودخول المساعده الانسانيه
بالاضافه الى تخصيص لجنه امميه دوليه
لتسهيل دخولها لاشراف فيها على كافه
الاسرى من الجانبين وتسهيل مهام بعثات
الامم المتحده وبرامج الغذاء العالمي من
خلال تعيين قوه خاصه لتامين مهامهم داخل
الاراضي السودانيه واوضحت المصادر ان هذه
المناقشات تدور حول توقيت وقف اطلاق النار
والانسحاب الى خطوط يتم الاتفاق عليها
وكشفت المصادر ايضا وجود مشاورات حول
تشكيل لجنه دوليه محايده مسؤوله عن
التحقيق في الاحداث الحاليه في السودان
السياق اكد وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح
شكري اكد ان بلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع
الاطراف السودانيه المتنازعه من اجل
استئناف الحوار السلمي لتسويه الوضع
بينهما وجدد شكريه تاكيد ايضا على ضروره
ان يمتنع جميع اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ
الاجانب عن تصعيد الوضع في السودان معبرا
عن امله في التوصل الى حل قريب بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه
ما تشاركه او ما تشاركه البرهان وحميطي
على مدى السنوات الماضيه افسدته رصاصه
خرجت منذ اربعه ايام من قلب العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لتتحول بعدها البلاد
الى ساحه حرب يديرها من كان يعد بحمايتها
وحلف امس بات عدو اليوم
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدارفورد اما وصفه
الصداع فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين
مسلحتين داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي
تقاتل فيها قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي
افريقيا كان في جنوب السودان وقتل حينها
حوالي 400 الف شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع
استقرار جارتها الشماليه وما يدور حاليا
فيه قد ينتهي فقط بفوز احدهم في المعركه
مع عدم استبعاد حرب اهليه طويله الامد قد
تجر جيرانها وفق صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه
تدعم القوات المسلحه السودانيه فيما اخبر
البرهان الصحيفه الغربيه انه بمجرد اكتمال
الانتقال الى الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده
الى التكنات وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
ومشاهدينا نرصد الاوضاع من الخرطوم مع
مراسل العربيه سلم الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك
معنا
الكل كان ينتظر بدء هذه الهدنه لوقف اطلاق
النار وفتح المجال للتهدئه من جهه وكذلك
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه من
جهه اخرى ولكن الاشتباكات استمرت كيف هو
تطور هذه الاشتباكات كيف هي الخرطوم فيما
اعتقد بانها اول ساعه تهدئه من بدء هذه
الهدنه
نعم منذ ان اعلنت الهدنه لقد قبولا كبيرا
من الاوساط السياسيه وكذلك الوسط الشعبيه
هنا في الخرطوم ظنا منهم انها يمكن ان
تحقق شيئا من المعادله الانسانيه في
الاحتياجات والضروريه التي يحتاجها
المواطنون هنا كان ينتظر المواطنون ان
تكون هذه الهدنه بدايه
لتصحيح بعض الاخطاء فيما يتعلق بالعون
الذي ياتي للمواطنين والخدمات التي
يحتاجونها لكن للاسف تفاجا المواطنون انه
منذ الساعه الاولى لانطلاق هذه الهدنه
ترتفع اصوات المدافع الثقيله الطائرات
وكذلك تبادل اطلاق النار في امراض مناطق
مختلفه من العاصمه الخرطوم
سالم ما المناطق يعني نتحدث على محيط
القياده العامه فقط
اوسعت رقعه الاشتباكات في الاخرى
ليست في محيط القياده العامه وحدها بل في
كل المناطق التي تشهد هذه الاشتباكات بدلا
من القياده العامه للجيش وامتدادا الى
كذلك القصر الجمهوري
وما حوله ايضا مطار الخرطوم شهد ايضا اعير
في ذلك الوقت هنا في مدينه بحري ايضا كان
هناك
مضادات للطائرات وكان هناك طائرات تحلق في
سماء بعض من مدينه بحري وايضا اصوات
الاعير الناريه في مدينه كانت تنطلق من
المظلات جهه الجسر الرابط بين ام درمان
وبحري جسر شامبات وكذلك من جهه المحطه
الوسطى في بحري وكذلك من كارفور مربع سته
كل هذه المناطق انطلقت منها اصوات مضادات
الطائرات وكذلك
انطلقت منها كذلك لعيره الناريه منذ بدايه
هذه الهدنه ما يفهم منه ان هذه الهدنه
ربما كانت يعني
وعدا من الطرفين لكنها الان ليست موجوده
على الارض في كل الحالات سنناقش هذه
النقطه هذه الهدنه لماذا لم يلتزم بها
الاطراف ولكن ابقى معي سالم اسمح لي فقط
ان اتابع هذه الصور مشاهدينا هذه الصور
مباشره من العاصمه الخرطوم حيث يعلو صوت
اطلاق الرصاص وكذلك قذائف المدفعيه نحن
نتحدث عن ساعه ونصف منذ انطلاق ما كان
يسمى هدنه اتفق عليها الطرفان بمتابعه
امميه وبمقترح اممي ولكن كما افادنا
مراسلنا منذ قليل وكما افاد كذلك مراقبون
وكما تعبر الصوره كذلك التي نتابعها لحظه
بلحظه الاشتباكات لم تنقطع اطلاق القذائف
المدفعيه كذلك لم ينقطع مضادات الطائرات
والاصوات التي نتابعها في سماء الخرطوم مع
تحليق بعض الطائرات كذلك استمر قبل بدء
هذه الهدنه
وخللها
والطرفين في الواقع بحسب ما افاد من
تصريحات كل طرف يتهم الطرف الاخر بعدم
التزامه بالهدنه
باستمراره في الاشتباك سواء الدعم السريع
او الجيش السوداني اذا مراسل العربيه كذلك
افادنا منذ قليل باستمرار القتال وهو ما
منع ايصال المساعدات نحن نشير الى ان والي
الخرطوم كان اجتمع مع مسؤولين وكذلك مع
جهات النافذه في الخرطوم لمحاوله
الاستفاده من هذه الخطه من هذه الخطه من
هذه الهدنه لايصال المساعدات الاغاثيه
والانسانيه والغذائيه
للمتضررين في داخل السوداني في الخرطوم
بتحديد ولكن هذه الهدنه استمرت فيها
الاشتباكات وبالتالي تعذر عمل هذه الفراق
اذا نستمع لبعض اللحظات لصوت الطبيعي
واعود لك سالم بعد قليل
سنبقى دائما مع هذه الصور مشاهدينا
سنتابعها ونتابع كذلك تطوراتها ونسال
بخصوصها كذلك ضيفنا من الخرطوم محمد مهدي
نائب المدير القطري في لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه في السودان سيد مهدي اهلا بك معنا
الكل كان ينتظر بدايه هذه الهدنه لايصال
المساعدات لمن ينتظرها ولكن هذه
الاشتباكات استمرت وفي داخل السودان يقال
بان
تعذر وصول هذه الفرق حدثنا اكثر عن عملكم
مع انطلاق هذه الهدنه هل فعلا تعذر عليكم
الوصول الى بعض الاحياء
سيد محمد هل تسمعني نعم هل تسمعيني اسمعك
بطريقه ممتازه حضرتك سمعتني سمعت سؤال ولا
اعيده سمعت تفضل نعم بما يخص الهدنه حقيقه
كان في ترقب
لتقييم الوضع على الارض وكما سمحتم يوجد
لحد الان صراحه اصوات اطلاق عيارات ناريه
وانفجارات بامر وتيره مختلفه
كنا نتامل ان بصراحه ان يكون هذه
الهدنه
تنطوي على اجراءات عمليه على الارض بما
يساهم ويساعد الفرق الطبيه من التنقل لان
حاليا الوضع لازال ماساوي بما يخص الخدمات
الطبيه
ولكن بالنسبه لعملكم استاذ محمد
مع استمرار الاشتباكات توقف العمل تماما
نعم في الخ تحديدا جميع نشاطاتنا صراحه
توقفت منذ اليوم الاول وهذا بسبب انعدام
او استحاله الحركه لفرقنا للوصول الى
العيادات التي نقوم بمساندتها لتقديم
الخدمات الصحيه الاوليه وخدمات التغذيه في
منطقه مختلفه من الخرطوم هذا بما يخص
الخرطوم لكن في ولايات اخرى من السودان
حيث تقدم لجنه لقاده الدولي خدمات خدماتها
الصحيه وخدمات التقنيه بالاضافه الى خدمات
حمايه المراه
وخدمات الماء والصحيات استمر العمل مثل
الولايات النيل الازرق وولايه الغضارف لكن
مع الاسف ليس الحال بما يخص الخرطوم بسبب
استمرار القتال والمواجهات وصعوبه التحرك
فرقنا في في الخرطوم طيب سيد محمد طالما
حضرتكم جهزتم انفسكم للخروج ولنقل هذه
المساعدات فالاكيد بانكم حذرتم قمتم
بتحضير كميات حدثنا اكثر عن المناطق
المتضرره عن الصوره في العموم عن المناطق
التي تستوجب تدخل اكثر من غيرها في عموم
السودان
صراحه لا يوجد تقييم دقيق
بامور الاضرار تحديدا لانه
توجد عشوائيه في بعض الاحيان بما يخص
المناطق المتضرره تعرف لانه في اطلاق نار
كثيف يحدث في عده احيان يحدث في مثلا قصف
لكن المقر التي هي يعني معروفه بما يخص
حده القتال هي سابقا حوالين منطقه المطار
منطقه القصر وفي مناطق من اطراف الخرطوم
شمالا هذه اغلب المناطق التي تكررت فيها
حدوث الاقتتال والانفجارات لكن هذا لا
يعني تاثر بقيه المناطق
بمستويات مختلفه
استمرار صراحه القتال قد يؤدي الى الى الى
مزيد من التحويل يؤدي الى مزيد من
الصعوبات
في شحن العائله فقط
سيد محمد ساعتذر منك اسمح لي على المقاطعه
ولكن هناك اصوات في الواقع عنيفه جدا
لانفجارات اصوات انفجار عنيف في داخل
الخرطوم
سنستمع لهذه الاصوات كنا نتابع اصوات
انفجارات وكذلك اطلاق نار واقتتال داخلي
اصوات مدفعيه ولكن منذ قليل كان هناك صوت
الانفجار كبير هزه العاصمه الخرطوم ستبقى
العين على هذه الصور اعود لك سيد محمد كنت
تتحدث عن المساعدات ولكن لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه تختص فقط في المساعدات ام ان
عملكم كذلك موسع ويمكن ان
تقدم خطه
هناك انفجار ثاني طيب سيد محمد هناك
انفجار ثاني كذلك داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
ساترك لصوت الطبيعي نستمع قليلا واعود لك
سيد محمد ابقى معي لو سمحت
هذه هي صوره مشاهدينا من داخل الخرطوم
استمعنا الى صوت انفجار اول كان عنيف جدا
وتلاه كذلك صوت انفجار ثاني مع شرارات من
النار ولكن الصوره غير واضحه وبالتالي
سنعود الى المزيد من التفاصيل حينما تتوفر
مع
ماسه يتضح في الدقائق القادمه
نحن نتابع هذه الصوره وتبقى العين عليها
لنفهم ما الذي يحدث كان الكل في انتظار
الهدنه التي ستسهل اولا طرح حلول للتهدئه
امكانيه ان تمدد هذه الهدنه وكذلك حتى طرح
حلول
اقامه اذان العشاء اعتقد في داخل الخرطوم
اعود لك سيد محمد اعود لك حضرتك كنت تتحدث
عن المساعدات ولكن هل المستشفيات كذلك من
المواضيع التي تتابعونها لان كان هناك
حديث عن تعطل خدمه مستشفيات كيف هي الحاله
نعم بالنسبه لعمل لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
نحن في الخرطوم تحديدا ندعم مستوصف صحفي
في اطراف الخرطوم حاليا متوقف تماما عن
الخدمه بصدق بسبب عدم امكانيه وصول الكادر
الطبي الى المستوصف وعدم امكانيه تزويد
المستوصف
بالادويه صراحه والمعدات الطبيه المطلوبه
لتواجدها في مكان اخر من الخرطوم
نراقب الوضع عن كثب
الامكانيه وصول الكادر يعني الاولويه
والاسبقيه بالنسبه لنا هو استمرار تقديم
الخدمات في هذه المنطقه من ضمنها الناس
المتضررين من جراء
القمر الوضع العام فيما يخص المستشفيات
حسب المعلومات المتوفره بصوره ما هناك
هناك نقص حاد بالادويه هناك نقص بالكادر
الطبي بسبب عدم امكانيات التنقل وتاثرهم
باقتتال الجائر زائدا عدم امكانيه وصول
المصابين نفسهم الى المستشفيات لاستقبال
الخدمه وعكس ازدياد الاعداد للناس اللي
موجودين داخل المستشفيات حاليا الكثير
منها توقف عن توفير الخدمات للاسباب
المذكوره
نقابه الاطباء تقدر عدد المستشفيات التي
خرجت عن الخدمه الى ما يقارب 17 مستشفى
في عموم السودان خرج تماما عن الخدمه
نعم هذه حسب معلومات من المتوفره حاليا
لكن لا يمكن تاكيد العدد تحديدا لكن الوضع
العام هو صراحه الامور التي وصفتها قله
الادويه عدم امكانيه وصول المصابين عدم
امكانيه الوصول للكادر الطبي الى المشافي
وتقديم الخدمات تاثر بعض المناطق
بالاقتتال الدائر او الجائر
يسبب عدم امكانيه وصولهم لتلقي تلك
الخدمات الوضع ماساوي كذلك عدم توفر
الطاقه الكهربائيه اثر على عدم المستشفيات
بصوره عامه هذا سيد محمد تحدثنا عن
المساعدات ولكن فهمت من كلام حضرتك بانكم
تحتاجون للمزيد من المساعدات لان التقييم
ليس دقيق حتى هذه اللحظه هناك احياء لم
تتمكنوا من الوصول لها هل هناك مساعدات من
الخارج قادره ان تصل السودان خاصه مع
المعلومات التي تفيد بعدم قدره للجان ولا
الفرق الى دخول السودان
نعم بالنسبه لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه نحن جزء
من المنظمات الانسانيه التي تنسق فيما
بينها لغرض بالاضافه الى التنسيق اكيد مع
منظمات الامم المتحده لغرض معرفه الواقع
على الارض
والتخطيط لامكانيه توفير مساعدات اذا سمحت
على الارض طبعا فالتنسيق هو ما بين
المنظمات بالاضافه الى المعلومات العامه
المتوافره حاليا التنسيق بالتاكيد
مراكزها الرئيسيه لغرض الوقوف على ما يدور
خارج السودان من ناحيه المناصرات من ناحيه
جمع المعلومات ما هي امكانيه تقديم الدعم
من خارج السودان الى السودان لكن على
الارض صراحه لا زال التركيز هو تامين
حمايه الناس حمايه الموظفين
ودراسه امكانيه اجراء تقييم ملموس
للاحتياجات وكل هذا متوقف على امكانيه
التحرك الى النقل وضحت الفكره بالتوفيق
لكم في هذا الوقت الحرج من الخرطوم محمد
مهدي نائب المدير في لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
في السودان شكرا جزيلا لك سيد محمد
ومشاهدينا نشير الى هذه الصور على الجانب
الايسر من الشاشه نحن تبع صور
لحرق سوق في خرطوم بحري كما وردت
المعلومات
نتابع التداعيات هذا
عمليه الحرق هذا هي صور خاصه وحصريه لقناه
العربيه
لحريق طالع هذا السوق في منطقه خرطوم بحري
ونتابع هذا
الفيديو مشاهدينا نتابع بانه تقريبا السوق
كله اكيد بانه هذا السوق كان عباره على
اماكن مجهزه باقمشه ربما
على اعمده موضوعه الاعمده لا زالت موجوده
ولكن كل ما في السوق تم حرقه نذهب الى
الفيديو ونعود
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
[موسيقى]
انا لله وانا اليه راجعون هذا قدر الله
[تصفيق]
عود من جديد الى زميلنا سالم الهاشمي
العربيه من الخرطوم سالم في الواقع هناك
خبران مهمان نود الاستعلام عليهما اكثر
الاول هو الفيديو الذي تابعناه بالاخير
احتراق سوق في خرطوم بحري هل لك معلومات
اضافيه فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
نعم سوق بحري كنا فيه نهارا ذهبنا اثناء
ساعات هذا الحريق كانت في النهار حوالي
الساعه
الثانيه تقريبا ظهرا كان هذا الحريق
الحريق اندلع
او بدا من قبل الساعه الثانيه قبل الساعه
الثانيه في حوالي الساعه الحاديه عشره
والنصف بدا هذا الحريق ذهبنا الى هناك
وجدنا الحريق ينتهي السوق بكثافه وجدنا
العديد من
الكثير من
وجدنا الكثير من
مجموعات الذين قد
الكثير نعم
هنا ايضا فيما يخص السوق لا اعلم انت اين
انا الان بالقرب في منطقه الصافيه حيث
المواطنون متجمهرون هنا يبحثون عن الوقود
في احدى محطات تعبئه الوقود تجهر
المواطنون
وسياراتها طويله جدا يبحثون عن الوقود
الصوت للحظات ولكن اسمحلي سالم لضيق الوقت
ساعود معك للانفجارات التي طالت محيط
القياده العامه بالخرطوم كان هناك انفجار
اول هز الخرطوم او هز على الاقل محيط
القياده العامه
هل معك تفاصيل هل توضح لنا صوره لان ما
استمعنا له في الواقع لم نشاهده من قبل
فيما قبل هناك مدفعيه هناك الشبكات على
الارض ولكن الانفجار كان جدا قوي
نعم هذه وهذه الاشتباكات بدات من بعد
اعلان هذه الهدنه او مع ابو عيده ساعات
الهدنه واطلاق هذه الهدنه ويضطر ان تبدا
ساعاتها مباشره
وجدنا ان هذه الاشتباكات تتجدد مره اخرى
وهناك مضادات للطائرات في مناطق مختلفه
ليست محيط القياده وحدها بل في مناطق
عديده جدا من الخرطوم
وخرطوم بحري كذلك وانظر معه هذه المناطق
كلها كان عليها هجوم مكثف بمضادات
الطائرات وكانت هناك طائره كذلك
هذه الطائره تحوم في سماء الخرطوم ايضا
هنا ايضا لدينا خبر مؤكد بان هناك ثلاثه
افراد من اسره واحده وهم اخوه في منطقه
شرق شرق النيل وهي الجريف شرق في بحري
نقول حتفهم باصابتهم بقذيفه من امام
هذا بعيد الافطار مباشره ليزداد عدد
بثلاثه اشخاص من اسره واحده
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
شكرا جزيلا لك نتابع دائما مع هذه
التطورات مع ضيفنا من الخرطومه دكتور رشيد
ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه بمركز
العلاقات الدوليه والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم
اهلا بك معنا وكذلك هنا في الاستوديو هشام
سلمان الكذاب الباحث والكاتب السياسي
السوداني اهلا بك معنا سيد هشام اسمح لي
ان ابدا من الخرطوم معك سيد ابراهيم سيد
ابراهيم ما نتابعه الان من خرقا لهذه
الهدنه من يتحمل مسؤوليته في ظل تبادل
الاتهامات بين الطرفين بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
نعم من الواضح ان هذه الهدنه وقعت على عجل
وان بها هشاشه كبيره لانه دائما الهدنه
التوقيت فيها مهم صحيح ان هنالك قضايا
انسانيه ملحه وان هنالك ظروف موضوعيه
تقتضي ان التسرع فيها ولكن دائما
الاجراءات التي يتعلق بالهدنه تكون في
توقيت على الاقل يكون هنالك رغبه من
الاطراف للدخول في هذه الهدنه
وهم اكثر رضا ولكن واضح ان هنالك ضغوطات
مورست عليهم وهم لم يكونوا مقتنعين تماما
انا في تقدير بهذه الخطوه كما ان عامل
الصيغه ايضا
يعني ضعيف جدا
الهدنه ايضا كانت في يومها الاول ودائما
الهدنه في يومها الاول هي تكون محل جدل
كبير جدا ايضا يعني حتى نفهم يعني هذا
الاجراء ولكن دكتور رشيد هذه ليس بالهدنه
الاولى او على الاقل ليس بالمقترح الاول
كان هناك مقترح اول من يومين بالامس كذلك
كان هناك مقترح ثاني كلها خرقت وهذه
الهدنه قيل بانها سيتم تفضل
بالهدنه الاولى انه الذي تم اتفاق على
ممرات امنه لساعات ثلاث ولكن الهدنه دائما
تاخذ وقتا اكبر يعني من يوم او يومان او
ثلاث يعني المصطلح هكذا ولكن ايضا في
النهايه اذا كان لم لم يتم الالتزام
بالمرور الامنه الانساني لمده ثلاثه ساعات
فكيف نتوقع ان يتم الالتزام ب 24 ساعه
يعني هذا غير صحيح ولكن اسمح لي ان نسال
كذلك ضيفنا هنا معنا في الاستوديو السيد
هشام سلمان كتاب سيد هشام هل تتفق مع ضيفي
على ان هذه الهدنه هي هشه اولا تم خرقها
بكل سهوله وبان هذه الهدنه تاسست على
اطراف هناك ازمه ثقه بينهم وليس هناك
نيه حقيقيه ورغبه حقيقيه لتثبيت هذه
الهدنه تتفق معه
بضيوفك انا بفتكر انك انت يعني عجبتي على
السؤال لانه
هو مش الثقه بس وغياب الاراده عندهم غياب
الاراده عامل مهم لانه في اشتراطات لاي
هدنه او سلام او او اي حاجه يعني او حتى
مباحثات
شروط كثيره لكن اهمها شرطين الشرط الاول
اللي هو الشرط الثقه توفر الثقه الثقه
المتبادله ودي ما موجوده
وتوفر الاراده او غيابه في حال غيابه
معناها ما ممكن يقوم اي نوع من التفاهم
فاذا كان الناس بتتكلم عن عن انه يكون في
هدنه وهي بتواجه كل المصاعب فما بالك لو
جينا نتكلم يعني عن عن حاجه اعلم ان
الهدنه يعني
لكن انا بفتكر انه في
في معادله غايبه هنا
يعني في جزء من المعادله غايه في ضلع ما
موجود الوشعب السوداني الناس دي كلها يعني
يفترض
فيهم انه يضعوا في الحزبان الشعب السودان
لانه الشعب السوداني هم
يعني هذا يعتبر يعني الحرب ذي بتعتبر مهدد
مباشر بالنسبه للشعب السوداني بتختلف
الشعب السوداني كما نتابع على الاقل من
خلالها وقع التواصل الاجتماعي نائب بنفسه
عن هذه الحرب وقال بانه لن نكرر حربا
اهليه نحن
تحملنا تداعياتها
اخوي اذا انت اليوم
الطرفين
بيتكلموا عن انهم هم ممثلين لثوره الشعب
السوداني الطرفين بيتكلموا على انهم هم
يعني مؤمنين بالثوره السودانيه ايوه لكن
هم لا ما هو انت اليوم ما دام انا بتكلم
ما هي اوكي لكن انا بتكلم انه الشعب
بيتحرك عبر ممثلين
وين السياسيين السودانيين اين هم ده سؤال
اللي بيفرض نفسه خلينا ننقل الضيفنا
سيد دكتور رشيد دكتور رشيد غياب
المكون السياسي الممثل للشعب الى اي مدى
ساهم في اخفاق هذه الهدنه واضره بامكانيه
تحقيق تهدئه في هذه المرحله
نعم هو ضلع مهم جدا لانه الهدنه والتاديه
عمليه متكامله ليست عمليه عسكريه
للاطراف المتصارعه ولكن عمليه ايضا تاهيم
منظمات المجتمع المدني تهم ايضا الاحزاب
السياسيه ولكن للاسف الشديد احزابنا
السياسيه هي في موقع المتفرج رغم انها هي
جزء من الازمه التي حدث حدثت الان بسوء
ادارتها
للعمليه السياسيه
وباشتراطاتها ولعدم التنبه للمحازير التي
ظلت تردد وتبس والتحليلات والحدث جزء منبر
مهم في هذه القضيه كذلك ايضا
يعني الاحزاب هي نفسها تحتاج الى اصلاح هي
الان تتحدث عن اصلاح امني واصلاح قضائي
ولكن لا توجد احزاب كامله من ناحيه الهيكل
من ناحيه الموضوعات من ناحيه البرامج كان
يمكن هذه الاحزاب ان
تقصداح السياسي هذا موضوع قادر ان نناقشها
في قادم الايام تتحدث حضرتك على
فقدان دور الحضور السياسي او حضور مكون
السياسي في مثل هكذا مرحله حساسه لماذا
هذا الدور مفقود هل لان الاحزاب ليست بقوه
المكونات التي نتابعها والتي تملك السلاح
وهي موجوده على الارض ام لحسابات اخرى في
داخل السوداني
لانه لا توجد احزاب بالمختصر المفيد يعني
الموجود هذه اسماء ولافتات وشعارات ولكن
القدره على الفعل ليست موجوده
ويختبرها الواقع او يكذب ما اقول ليس لها
قدره على الحشد الجماهير ما قيمه الاحزاب
وما معنى الحزب ان لم يكن لديه تواصل مع
الجمهور ما قيمه الاحزاب والتنظيمات
السياسيه ان لم يكن لها غدره على اقناع
الاطراف
المتحاربه على هدنه عمرها 24 ساعه الاحزاب
التي لا تستطيع ان تحرك الشارع وتصنع
تاريخا لنفسها وتقول يعني يعني كلمه في في
عمره مفصلي من تاريخ السودان هذه ليست
احزاب احزاب الاحزاب ليست للسلطه فقط
ولجلسات التفاوض واغتسام كيكه السلطه
والاختلاف حول حصص الوزاره هذا هذه هي
الازمه الحقيقيه اتكلم عن ديموقراطيه
ومدنيه بدون ادوات للديمقراطيه والمدنيه
وبالتالي تبغى دائما معادله الامن مقابل
الحريات هي حاضره في المشهد السياسي
السوداني اضف الى الاسباب التي دعت الى ان
تكون هذه الهدنه هشه انه كل طرف يحاول ان
يحسن من موقفه العسكري الميداني حتى يكون
لديه مساحه تفاوضيه اكبر وهذا ما لاحظناه
بدقه في اللحظات او في الساعه الاخيره
التي سبقت التنفيذ او دخول الهدنه لحيز
التنفيذ لاحظنا هجوما على القياده لهذا
لاحظنا ضربا لبعض المواقع مما يؤكد على ان
هنالك
ولكن دكتور اسمحلي ان اتحول فقط بالسؤال
هو استكمالا لفقرات حضرتك بان هناك غياب
سياسي
سيد هشام يقول البعض بانه الوقت الراهن
يجب ان يرتفع صوت العقل صوت المنطق وصوت
الخبره السياسيه من يمتلكها في داخل
السوداني والله هو انا دعيني يعني اختلف
مع ضيفي تختلف في بعض الاماكن انه يعني
انا بفتكر انه هو ان احنا كل الموروث بتاع
النظام السابق هو فيه مشاكل
لكن انا بفتكر انه الشعب السوداني الثوري
دي حقه الشعب السوداني بما فيه من كل
المكونات
المكونات دي سواء كان مكونات المدنيه
والسياسيه للاحزاب يعني لكن السؤال
المفرد نفسه هنا ما نحن المشاكل دي ما
موجود في الحسابات السياسيه بس المشاكل دي
حتى موجوده في المكونات العسكريه والدليل
على كده ان المكونات العسكريه دي عندها
سوء تقدير لا مره ولا اثنين ولا ثلاثه لم
يقل ليست موجوده هو قال مكون السياسي
كل المشكله انا انا ما بتفق معه في جزء
مختلف معاه في جزئين انا بس داير ابرز سوء
التقدير مثلا
سواء التقدير عند المكونات العسكري
المكونه العسكري قام بيفضل الاعتصام كان
سوء وتقدير واضح فيه خرق لامن وطمانينه
الشعب السوداني
قام بخرق مره ثانيه بينه عمل انقلاب 25 او
استولى على سلطه تسموه اجراءات تصحيحيه
يسموه اي شيء المهم هي انتهت من الفتره
الانتقاليه
بالمره الثالثه سوء التغدير حرب في نص
المدينه في العاصمه اللي هو روحوا فيها
ضحايا انت بتتكلم باسمه سواء كنت انت مكون
عسكري او مدني انت بتتكلم باسم الشعب
السوداني يفترض انك انت تنتخي لانه صعبه
الشعب السوداني قام بثوره
عندها سقف
التغيير وسقفه الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
دي نمره واحد اثنين عندها استراتيجيه
استراتيجيه السلميه ما نحن لو كنا عايزين
نتحارب كان شلنا البشيرنا سلاح شعب
السوداني ما شال السلاح شال البشير وكان
مصير على الاستراتيجيه بتاعته اللي هي
السلميه لكن
العساكر حاليا هم يعني ماشيين في الاتجاه
اللي صعدوا الموضوع ده عسكريا ويستخدموا
لغه السلاح ليه
هل ده بيديك تفويض ما هي الفتره
الانتقاليه هذه يقال من يملك السلاح يملك
الارض هو يملك الارض لكن لا يملك لا يملك
حاجتين مهمتين لا يملك لا يملك الشرعيه
ولا يملك التفويض التفويض ده في فتره زي
دي بيكون بالتراضي صحيح
واذا انت عايز شرعيه بتكون بالانتخابات هو
على كل الموضوع هذا يطول بخصوصه الحديث
والنقاش وان القاك ربما في نشرات اخرى
سنكتفي بهذا القدر سنتابع الصوره من داخل
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك هشام سلمان الكتابه
الباحث والكتابه السياسي السوداني وشكر
كذلك الحذر من الخرطوم الدكتور رشيد
ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه بمركز
العلاقات الدوليه والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم
شكرا لكما
ومشاهدينا سنتابع ببعض الاخبار ذات الصله
حيث قال مسؤول المساعدات بالامم المتحده
مارتن جريفيث قال ان استهدف موظفي مساعده
الاغاثيه والمنشات الخاصه بعمليات الاغاثه
في السودان لا يزال مستمرا واضاف في
تغريده على تويتر ان الامم المتحده تتلقى
تقارير عن تعرض موظفها الاغاثه لهجمات
واعتداءات واعتبر جرافيث هذا غير مقبول
ويجب ان يتوقف مشيرا الى ان مكتب الامم
المتحده للمساعدات في جنوب دارفور تعرض
للنهبه
مع تواصل الاشتباكات تزداد الاوضاع
الانسانيه سوءا ويواجه سكان السودان من
الاطفال وكبار السن الرعب ومشاق النزوح
اي كلمات في محاولات بث الطمانينه لقلب
هذه الطفله المفزوعه ستظل طريقها على
الاغلب امام ذوي الانفجارات الشرسه في
محيط منزلها بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
حتى حيلوا الجداد بامتصاص رعب احفادهن
فشلت هذه الجده على ما يبدو من تحقيقها
انه اليوم الرابع من ايام حرب كسر العظم
كما توصف بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الحرب التي تزداد شراسه واتساعا مع
الايام قتلت منذ اندلاعها السبت الماضي
اكثر من 180 مدنيا واوقات نحو 1800 جريح
وفق الامم المتحده حتى اعداد هذا التقرير
وتخلف قصصا من الالم لدى نازحين بحثا عن
النجاد يتشاركون خلال رحله الاجبار هذه
مشقه اللجوء فبعضهم يفورو سيرا على
الاقدام وربما كان من سعداء الحرب من يجد
وسيله اخرى وحتى اللحظه تعجزوا على ما
يبدو تقارير محليه او دوليه عن تقدير
اعداد النازحين ورغم صعاب النزوح تبقى
خيارات من فارقوا ديارهم محدوده اذ تعم
رائحه البارود غالبيه المناطق في السودان
ثالث اكبر بلد افريقي مساحه واحد اكثر
البلدان فقرا في العالم
وربما تحيي موافقه الطرفين المتحاربين على
هدنه لمده 24 ساعه تنتهي مساء الغد تحيي
املها هؤلاء بهدوء يسمح لهم بعوده امنه
الى منازلهم حنان المصري العربيه
تطورات سياسيه وعسكريه متسارعه شهدها
السودان منذ اسقاط نظام عمر البشير عام
2019 بدايه من المظاهرات الحاشده وتشكيل
مجلس السياده وصولا الى تطورات الاخيره
والحرب التي انفجرت بين المكونين
العسكريين والتي تنظر بعوده الازمه الى
المربع الاول
في السودان اعوام مره مرت بعد فرح لم يدم
طويلا بسقوط نظام احكم قبضته على البلاد
30 عاما اذرعان ما دخلت البلاد نفقا
سياسيا ومؤسساسيا مظلما لم تخرج منه بعد
صراع تلو اخر بين المدنيين والعسكريين حول
السلطه عمق الازمه وزاد من حده التممل
والاستياء لدى المواطنين الذين علقوا
املهم على عهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
مظاهرات شعبيه كبيره تمكن من خلالها
السودانيون من ازاحه عمر البشير الذي ترك
تركه ثقيله على البلاد التي انتشر فيها
الفساد والنزاعات المسلحه الداخليه ابرزها
دارفور فعقب لطاحه به اجتماعات طويله
خاضتها قوى الحريه والتغيير مع المكون
العسكري في البلاد لرسم خريطه تضمن العوده
الى الشرعيه السياسيه عبر انتخابات
النزيهه غير ان حلم السودانيين لم يتحقق
تطورات متسارعه جاء اتباعا وتحديدا في
اغسطس 2019 مجلس السياده السوداني عين عبد
الله حمدوك رئيسا للوزراء لكنه لم يبقى
طويلا على راس الحكومه حيث انقلب عليه
الجيش في حمله اعتقالات طالته بالاضافه
الى عدد من وزراء حكومته بتاريخ الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021
ردت عليه الولايات المتحده بتعليق مساعدات
بقيمه 700 مليون دولار للسودان الشارع رد
ايضا بمظاهرات ضد المكون العسكري في
الخرطوم واغلقت الشوارع دعما للقوى
السياسيه والاحتواء الغضب الشعبي افرجت
القياده العسكريه وتحديدا في الرابع من
نوفمبر من نفس العام عن اربعه وزراء كانوا
في حكومه عبد الله حمدوك واقام البرهان
بتشكيل مجلس السياده الانت جديد استبعد
منه اربعه ممثلين لقوى الحريه والتغيير
هذه الفوضى ادت الى ترد الوضع الانساني
والغذائي في السودان فاعلن البنك الدولي
ملحمه مليون دولار للخرطوم مقابل تحويلات
ماليه وغذائيه في يوليو عام 2022 في
الخامس من ديسمبر عام 2022
وسطت الاليه الثلاثيه نجحت باعاده الاطراف
المتصارعه الى طاوله المفاوضات مجددا
فاسهمت في توقيع الاتفاق للطاريه المبدئي
بين العسكريين والقوى السياسيه في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وقبل ايام من التوقيع على
الاتفاق النهائي الذي يضم الجيش والدعم
السريع والقوى السياسيه انفجرت شراره
الحرب بين المكونين العسكريين في الخامس
عشر من هذا الشهر لتعيد البلاد الى المربع
الاول من الازمه
ومشاهدينا في نهايه هذه الساعه نشير الى
بعض العواجي التي كنا تبعناها اسفل شاشه
العربيه ولكن كنا نناقش بعض التطورات
فنذكر بها كذلك بعض بعض المواقف اولا
واشنطن والامم المتحده تؤكدان عدم النجاح
الهدنه في السودان حتى اللحظه موقف اخر من
الجامعه العربيه التي تدعو الاطراف
السودانيه للالتزام بالهدنه ووقف النار
وفيما يخص اخر التطورات كما تابعناها اسفل
شاشه العربيه مصادر الجيش السوداني تتحدث
عن مقاتلات تقصف مواقع الدعم السريع في
القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم والقوه السودانيه
السياسيه تحذر من خطر كبير على الدوله اذا
فشل وقف اطلاق النار على كل هذه الساعه
انتهت ولكن تغطيه العربيه نزلت مستمره بعد
قليل تستكملون متابعه التفاصيل مع زميل
نجال الاختيار ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات